in den 80er 90er Jahren war made in
Italy in ganz Europa auf dem Vormarsch
doch diese Erfolgsstory sollte in den
2000er Jahren eine Jesus Ende finden die
abwertungsstrategie Roms wurde durch
gleich zwei voneinander unabhängige
historischen Großereignisse gnadenlos
durch kreuzt na kommt ihr drauf welche
die sparen ganz genau erstens Tat China
damals der Welthandelsorganisation bei
und zweitens Italien dem Euro das
Ergebnis mit den noch billigeren Preisen
der chinesischen Unternehmen konnten
Italiener nicht konkurrieren und ihre
Währung konnten sie auch nicht mehr
abwerten die Kombination dieser beiden
ökonomischen Veränderungen löste eine
lange Krise aus aus der Italien bis
heute nicht herausgekommen ist heute ist
Italien eines der größten Problemländer
Europas und daran trägt silikoni einen
gewaltigen Teil der Schuld das heutige
Italien ist das Ergebnis dessen was
besonders Kolonie getan oder besser
nicht getan hat und das obwohl er mehr
Macht besaß als fast jeder andere
Politiker
[Musik]